so he kind of looks like the first
version of this okay that guy all right
so kalisto was the kind of guy where
i'm not kidding you we would walk into a
bar
and women would walk up to him not
even introduce themselves and start
making out with them oh
did i maybe i might have did he ever go
to
i'm being serious did he ever go to your
rustic
maybe yeah what about the virgil yes
because i definitely have ran my fingers
through
a very uh richard ramirez type like i
ran my fingers through someone's hair
oh my god that would be that would be a
nightmare and i randomly made it is the
only guy i've ever walked up to and made
out with oh
a my god would be a nightmare but anyway
so he was that type of guy okay
and imagine me i couldn't get anybody to
even
say hello so i'm walking in with you
know my friend kalisto
women are making out with them and then
i'm like i'm the guy at the jukebox
looking through the like songs
you've done it three times already yeah
yeah and i'm also the guy that puts the
coins in who does that the only person
i'm putting coins in i'm going
okay d12 you too you know what i mean
whatever
it might be so i did too that's what i
did right and then here's the second
thing i would do
i would go and i go i wonder if they had
that uh that um
that game you know on the on the bar
where you could
the photos were like check out the
differences
so i would be the guy just all night
playing that game right it's like
circling or whatever like it's so sad
so um but i used to live with kalisto
right and we used to have these thin
walls right
and every night would be a different
woman right
and it would be this is i swear to god
this is what the sex
oh yeah this is right once
oh yeah yeah oh that's it
and that you would hear the girl go
that's it and he's sleeping
so i don't think that he was good in the
bed
and then like i would sometimes see the
women in the kitchen and just go
that's it you know what i mean that's
what he did you know what i mean yeah
so it's like and number two he kalisto
too
oh god stop saying his name because
first you said we can keep his name in
because you're going to say something
nice about it i am saying nice we
were walking he was he was a talent i'm
not done so
also the listen here's how i met kalisto
right in my early 20s i'll tell you
after this story how i met kalisto
did you really meet him i don't know
so no i don't know we don't know
you said he used to go to your rustic
yeah and one time i randomly made up
with a guy like that looks like that and
then you re
at the heuristic that happened though oh
my god it would break
but then afterwards i made sure because
i sometimes i get blurry vision when i
drink
so i asked jessica afterwards i was like
hey dude was he hot she was like dude he
was
ugly as [ __ ] so it couldn't have been
kalisto if he wasn't
in fact good looking because jessica has
confirmed i have
sometimes i just go for it i like my
argos
okay so anyway um the way i met kalisto
he was an actor
at um balboa theater like at the globe
like he was a legitimate actor and i
went and saw his plays
and he was singing and dancing on stage
it was like a big production you know
it was beautiful right he's a great
musician right
he's he's in a band right he does so
many things
but he's the type of guy that would do
12 things at one time
like i paint right i act
i'm in a band i do all these things and
i used to tell him i used to go
you first of all you you drink too much
right
and also you're just you just you get
way too much [ __ ]
right because most of your time is gav
gavalanting around town you mean trying
to get women
right and you're not focusing on one
craft
whereas when i was living with them all
i did was stand up
right wrote jokes went to coffee shops i
was living in silver lake with them
and this uh sometimes i would play video
games with my brother but it's like you
know i would
you know focus on one thing and i used
to tell him
focus on one thing but he wouldn't so i
think that him getting a lot of women
right right um [ __ ] him up
you know what i mean yeah anyway
thanks for listening to uh tiger belly
we'll see you the next time shout out to
callisto
hey guys hope you enjoyed that
valentine's day week special
what uh what an interesting one it's
always it's always crazy when it's just
bobby and kalyal on their own thoughts
with no guests to interrupt it
is it not george yes it is